♪ ♪
>> Katie: WOKE EDUCATION COULD
BE ON THE CHOPPING BLOCK.
SUPREME COURT READY TO RULE ON
TWO CASES.
A GROUP ACCUSING HARVARD AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF NORTH CAROLINA OF
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
ASIAN AMERICAN APPLICANTS BY
VALUING BLACK AND HISPANIC
STUDENTS MORE.
THE SCHOOLS ARGUE THE FRAMEWORK
IS NECESSARY TO CREATE DIVERSE
STUDENT BODY.
BIDEN'S U.S. SOLICITOR
GENERAL WENT A STEP FURTHER
SAYING AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IS
"CRITICAL NATIONAL SECURITY
PARODY."
IF LOCAL UNIVERSITIES CARE ABOUT
FAIRNESS, IT'S INTERESTING THAT
A MOST HALF OF WHITE STUDENTS
ARE ADMITTED INTO HARVARD AND I
RECRUITED ATHLETES, LEGACY
STUDENTS, DONORS AND STAFF.
THE LEFT LOSING THEIR MINDS WHEN
CLARENCE THOMAS SPOKE TO GET RID
OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
>> Greg: CRITICAL NATIONAL
SECURITY IMPERATIVE.
THE REASON THEY SAY THAT IS SO
WHEN IT GOES AWAY IT WILL BE A
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
WHEN WHITE STUDENTS ARE
DISAVOWING WHITE ON THE
APPLICANTS, A THIRD CHOSE
NONWHITE WHEN THEY TAKE THE BOX,
THAT TELLS YOU IT'S BETTER TO BE
NONWHITE, A QUALITY HAS BEEN
REACHED IN THE ACADEMIC SETTING,
AT SOME POINT AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
WAS NECESSARY BUT TRAINING
WHEELS ON A BIKE, SOMETIMES IT'S
GOT TO GO.
WHITE PRIVILEGE IS A MYTH IF
THERE IS NO WHITE PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO BE WHITE OTHER
APPLICATIONS.
RESEARCH IS ABOUT PREFERENCES,
FOR PARENTS AND RELATIVES WHO
DONATE TO HARVARD.
ALWAYS AN IMPLICIT JUDGMENT WHEN
PEOPLE MEET YOU.
DID YOU GET THERE IN CHARACTER,
COMPETENCE, OR COLOR?
>> Katie: WHITE STUDENTS COME
INTO THE DEBATE ABOUT
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
IT'S REALLY NOT ABOUT WHITE
PRIVILEGE --
>> Jessica: IT'S ABOUT A
LARGER DEBATE ABOUT AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION.
COLLEGE IS TRYING TO KID A
COMMUNITY OF LEARNERS, NOT THE
BEST TEST TAKERS.
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION GOES FURTHER
THAN TALK ABOUT RACE.
NO ONE IS DISCUSSING THE FACT
THAT IF YOU ARE SOMEONE WHO GREW
UP IN UTAH OR WYOMING THAT YOU
ARE LIKELY TO MORE GET ACCEPTED
TO A TOP UNIVERSITY THAN PEOPLE
OUT OF NEW YORK OR CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY OF THEM.
NO ONE ARGUING AND ON BEHALF OF
THESE ASIAN STUDENTS, HARVARD OR
UNC, SAYING THE BLACK --
THEY ARE NOT SEEN THE BLACK KIDS
WEREN'T QUALIFIED.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THE TEST
SCORES.
IF YOU'RE JUDGED ONLY BY YOUR
TEST SCORES, GOING TO END UP
WITH A LOT OF BOTS.
TAKING STANDARDIZED TEST IS
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR
CERTAIN KIDS.
KIDS WHO HAVE LEARNING
DISABILITIES, CAN'T PERFORM AS
WELL.
A IMPORTANT MARKER, THEY NEED TO
STAY FOR THINGS LIKE GOING TO
MEDICAL SCHOOL, I SEE WHY THE
LSAT IS IMPORTANT.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT YOUR
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE, WAS THE
PERSON YOU THOUGHT WAS MOST
INTERESTING THE ONES WHO HAVE
THE HIGHEST S.A.T. SCORE?
I DOUBT IT.
SOMEONE WHO WAS FROM A DIVERSE
BACKGROUND, SOMEONE WHO YOU
NEVER THOUGHT YOU'D MEET.
I GREW UP A CERTAIN WAY AND THE
PEOPLE I GRAVITATED TOWARDS
BECAUSE YOUR GOING TO A PLACE
FOR FOUR YEARS TO LEARN ABOUT
DIFFERENT PEOPLE, FOLKS WERE NOT
FROM NEW YORK CITY.
THAT'S FOR ME WHAT AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION IS ALL ABOUT.
>> Greg: GO AFTER PEOPLE THAT
ARE JUST INTERESTING?
THAT'S THE CRITERIA?
I AM HERE TO JUDGE IF YOU'RE
INTERESTING OR NOT.
YOU LOOK DIFFERENT.
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO DYE THEIR
HAIR PURPLE, JESSICA.
THAT WAS MY JESSE IMPRESSION.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: STUDENTS FOR FAIR
ADMISSIONS BRINGING THIS ON
BEHALF OF THEIR STUDENTS.
BUT THEY OBJECT TO IS THAT
CONSIDERATION OF RACE AND RACE
BY ITSELF.
FOR >> Dana: A COUPLE THINGS,
CLARENCE THOMAS HAD WHAT DOES
THE WORD DIVERSITY MEAN?
IT REALLY HAS BECOME THIS
CATCHALL TERM.
HIS POINT WAS IT CAN MEAN
WHATEVER YOU WANT IT TO MEAN.
THAT IS TO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION.
CARRIE SEVERINO, A LAWYER WHO
SAID THE UNIVERSITY TRIED TO
SUGGEST THAT THE RACIAL ASPECT
OF THEIR EMISSION STANDARDS HAD
LITTLE IMPACT ON ADMISSIONS BUT
THEY NEEDED IN ORDER TO HAVE
DIVERSITY.
I THINK THEY JUST WALKED
THEMSELVES INTO THE SITUATION
WHERE JOHN ROBERTS,
CHIEF JUSTICE SAID I'M NOT
BUYING IT.
THE OTHER THING, YOU KNOW WHAT
IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPERATIVE, THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE K-12 EDUCATION THAT IS SO
BAD AND LEARNING LOSS FROM COVID
WITH HORRIBLE TEST SCORES, THE
KEY TO MAKING SURE MORE PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO GOOD COLLEGES AND
GOOD TEST SCORES AND THE
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES THEY
DO IS TO IMPROVE K-12 EDUCATION.
IF YOU'RE LISTENING TO THIS
ARGUMENT AND YOUR ANSWER IS WE
REALLY NEED TO KEEP RACE-BASED
ADMISSIONS GOING BECAUSE --
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE A GOOD
ANSWER, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
IMPROVE K-12 EDUCATION?
YOU'RE ON THE WRONG TRACK.
>> Katie: INTERESTING TO WATCH
THE LEFT REACT TO MINORITIES WHO
DON'T BELIEVE IN AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION.
>> Jesse: I'M GOING TO PASS ON
THIS ONE.
>> Greg: YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO PASS.
>> Jesse: I'M CONFUSED BY THE
STORY.
WHO IS UPSET?
WHITES OR ASIANS?
JUST ASIANS ARE UPSET?
>> Dana: THEY BROUGHT THE
CASE.
>> Jessica: WHY PEOPLE ARE
ALSO UPSET THAT THEY ARE NOT --
>> Jesse: WHITE PEOPLE ARE
ALSO UPSET?
>> Jessica: THEY ARE NOT IN
THE CASES.
NOW THERE'S LESS OF AN ADVANTAGE
BECAUSE ASIANS STARTED TESTING
BETTER THAN WHITES.
DID YOU READ YOUR NOTES?
>> Jesse: ASIAN AMERICANS ARE
SAYING THEY'RE NOT GETTING
ACCEPTED BECAUSE WHY?
>> Greg: WHAT WERE YOU
THINKING ABOUT DURING THE
SEGMENT?
>> Dana: TOLD THAT YOU ARE NOT
LIKABLE ENOUGH.
VERY DISCRIMINATORY.
>> Jesse: THINK IF THEY DON'T
INTERVIEW WELL IN THE RESEARCH.
>> Greg: IT'S NOT AS
WELL-ROUNDED, THEY ARE KIND OF
RACIST.
THEY ARE SAYING ASIANS ARE
ROBOTS.
>> Jesse: THAT THE ASIANS
DIDN'T DO CLUBS IN HIGH SCHOOL,
OR SPORTS?
>> Greg: I L